chance to get through the detail yet and
once i've had a chance to do that and
hear what explanation is offered then
i'll come to a view is any explanation
good enough really if the prime minister
said parties didn't attend in the house
didn't occur
clearly parties did occur because the
met police have charged people for them
and sue gray spells it out really
clearly
what is there still to discover or what
is it what can the prime minister say
that that will make you think that he
didn't mislead parliament
most fair-minded people would say that
people are allowed the benefit of the
doubt now the prime minister has clearly
said he wants to defend his position he
wants to explain what happened and i'd
like to give him the chance to do that
but clearly that explanation is going to
have to be phenomenally good given that
we were told very clearly that there was
no party on the occasion where the
photographs were subsequently emerged
demonstrating that there was a party and
the prime minister was present but he
says he can explain that i want to give
him the chance to do that i want to hear
what he has to say and then i and i'm
sure many colleagues will take a view
about what the next steps should be
emily thornbury are you prepared to to
give the prime minister the benefit of
the doubt
no what doubt there isn't any doubt
anymore
um the public have been
pretty decided for a long time as have i
um and you know doubt about what i mean
there's the
today i think has to be the day when the
prime minister properly takes
responsibility for
being in charge of a culture at number
10 um where he lived and where he was in
charge where there was law breaking on a
scale that wasn't seen anywhere else in
the whole country and yet they were
responsible for the laws
and then
more importantly he should also take
responsibility for coming to parliament
and lying to us and telling us that
there were no rules broken and there
were no parties when clearly there were
and clearly he knew they were and
enough of all of this i mean really
enough he needs to resign he needs to go
we can't have any more there's been
dragging on forever and say the public
have already made up their minds and the
majority of the public today think that
he should be resigning i mean really the
question for me if i was able to ask a
question of prime minister's questions
would be
what would have been in the sued grey
report that might have ever got you to
resign how bad does it need to get
before you take proper responsibility i
mean you say i'm sure there'll be lots
of shuffling and he'll look down at the
floor and look terribly sorry
but he won't take any of the words will
be great but he won't take
responsibility if you take
responsibility more than talking about
it you resign you resign because you
allowed this all to happen
and then you resign more importantly
because you lied about it our very
democracy is based on the idea that
people cannot come to parliament and lie
and get away with it
otherwise how do we ever hold the
government to account if politicians are
just allowed to come in and lie with no
consequences
kirsty blackman from the snp also
joining us ahead of prime minister's
questions uh is there anything that the
prime minister can say that makes will
make you think that that he should stay
in his position
absolutely no there's been lie after lie
after lie i mean it wasn't just the fact
that all of this happened but actually
reading the sugree report makes you see
the sense of absolute entitlement that
goes on in that building the sense that
they're somehow better than the rest of
us and you know they're allowed to do
this they can do this you know with
impunity because they are better than
everybody else i mean martin reynolds
and we've only had the report for 15
minutes but martin reynolds said um he
talked about the drinks on the 20th of
may he said we seem to have got away
with it he clearly knew it was wrong it
was against the rules but they were
going to do it anyway because they're a
different level from the rest of us now
that
sense of entitlement coupled with the
lying is the key reason that boris
johnson should not be prime minister no
matter how many arguments you make about
the war in ukraine the amount of damage
that he has done to trust in politics
and politicians
means that he is not a fit leader he is
not a fit leader to take us through this
current massive crisis that we're having
with ukraine that we're having with the
cost of living i don't trust people with
this sense of entitlement to be able to
step up and help my constituents and
people across the uk
with the cost of living crisis that
they're that they are for um they are
going through because it's very clear
that these people live in a total bubble
and just don't care
okay we're going to pause you guys and
we're going to cross back to sam coats
who's been going through the report line
by line but we'll return to you all in a
moment if you would wouldn't mind
staying sam what have you found
just some of the briefest most ironic
parts of this report and uh you were
just hearing about that section martin
reynolds talking uh about the event on
the 20th of june best of luck a complete
non-story but better than them focusing
on ardrick's which we seem to have got
away with so the most senior official in
number 10 there admitting that there was
a problem with what they were doing now
look at this exchange it's between
martin reynolds again and lee kane it's
about an event uh the next month and lee
kane and martin ross have discussed
about what kind of event it should be
but like but look at this it's another
example of the people in number 10
understanding that they were going to
strain or break the rules and then
discuss who should get the blame if
they're caught lee kane at the end 632
is a whatsapp exchange i think it's your
decision my friend not mine i think not
mine but it obviously comes with rather
substantial comms risk so this is lee
kane sort of washing his hands of
political responsibility of that event
that's the event from the 18th of june
uh a leaving do uh and saying if you
decide to go ahead martin reynolds
that'll be on you uh and if you look at
this here we have uh at that event uh we
believe it was helen mcmurran's leaving
party uh the cabinet secretary mark said
will no longer in post uh uh actually
popped in uh for a short time and then
look at this the event lasted a number
of hours there was excessive alcohol
consumption by some individuals one
individual was sick there was a minor
altercation between two other
individuals there you have it there was
essentially a fight in the heart of
whitehall because of excessive alcohol
consumption now as sue gray says in her
conclusions it's for people at the top
of the political tree to take
responsibility but it's not clear yet
what that responsibility taking
responsibility like that is actually
going to look like
thanks very much sam let's return to our
people's panel david simmons uh
for speaking to us for the conservatives
our mp's panel sorry um
you
you know you've said you're gonna wait
to hear what the prime minister says but
when we look at
at what sam coats is going through and
what he's seen one thing that strikes me
the people who are talking about these
events are talking about being a comms
risk it's a pr risk they're worried
about they're worried about what it
looks like at no point do they appear to
be worried about the risk of actually
passing on covert
yes and this is the big problem and it
seems to me very clear the rules which
the prime minister announced a few days
beforehand which closed businesses
across my constituency meant people
couldn't get to see relatives who were
sick in hospital were designed to save
lives so the challenge for me is i
totally agree with the point that kirsty
was making we've got lots of big issues
going on in the world at the moment
we've got the northern ireland protocol
we've got situation in ukraine we've got
the cost of living we need to know that
people in government are focused on the
detail they're paying attention to
what's happening and they're ensuring
that the policies which broadly the
public support are bringing the benefits
bringing the outcomes that we want to
see and if it's clear that people in
government weren't really paying
attention to what was going on under
their noses that's a very major warning
sign but as i said any constituent who
was accused including those who were
fined was entitled to the benefit of the
doubt i'm going to give that to the
prime minister for the time being i want
to hear what he has to say and then i
and many of my colleagues will be making
up our minds what the next steps need to
be
do you think the prime minister has
damaged trust in politics david yes or
no
trust in politics is at a very low level
at the moment clearly this has made that
situation far worse
it's made it worse okay thank you emily
thornbury coming back to you for the
labour party of course uh some of the
events that we've looked at over these
uh times in downing street sue grey has
said were clearly work events uh where
there was alcohol others were not work
events um the police have certainly
regarded some of these as drinks at a
work event do you think that kiestarma
is going to be worried today after his
event in durham which was also a work
event
no pierced armor doesn't live on thin
air he has to eat and he was working in
durham and he had something to eat and
then carried on working there is no
issue with that the police will
investigate and we'll find that to be
the case and there's certainly no
equivalence with what was going on in
downing street i was looking at the
conclusions here of the sugree report
and paragraph 5
0.5 talks about the
multiple examples of the lack of respect
and poor treatment of security and
cleaning staff and how unacceptable that
was and we heard on panorama last night
about the security staff trying to stop
these parties and being laughed at
and being and being in the mickey being
taken out of them people doing the right
thing or trying to do the right thing
but the culture in number 10 having got
completely out of control and the person
who sits at the top of that who is
politically accountable is the prime
minister who also lied about it there is
it's open and shut and i know that
i can hear you know that the excuses
mounting which is you know the prime
minister has many other things to do
let's move on the fact of the matter is
is that whilst they continue to try to
protect the prime minister they are not
looking at the big issues of the day
which is most importantly which is the
cost of living crisis where we have told
the government months ago what they
should be doing in relation to people's
fuel bills and how we ought to have a
windfall tax and it may be that they're
about to agree to that but you know it's
months and months too late because
they've been spending their time trying
to defend the prime minister instead
okay we're very close to the to uh 12
o'clock and prime minister's questions
let's quickly go back to sam coates um
that shot there of the house of commons
we'll return to it of course when the
prime minister stands up but sam very
briefly what else have you found
one of the uh events most worrying
people in number 10 has been this the
party in the flat on the 13th of
november sue grey was investigated this
yellow section here reveals that she
didn't bother in the end when the police
decided that they weren't going to
investigate and there was nothing more
to say she also washed herself washed
her hands of the event so the most
potentially damaging uh flat allegations
of dancing in the flat she says
following the metropolitan police
announcement 19th of may says last week
i considered whether or not to conduct
any further investigation this event but
i concluded it was not appropriate or
proportionate to not do so so a clean
bill of health because she just never
investigated what happened in boris
johnson and carrie johnson's personal
flat after the police didn't do so
either
let's very briefly return to kirsty
blackman on that one
kirstie that i think that was the abba
party as it was dubbed so it appears
that sue gray didn't actually
now investigate that
yeah i think we need to have
justification for why she didn't she
didn't she says it's not proportionate
but you know this is one of the worst
allegations the prime minister just
can't wash his hands of this i mean this
is endemic and if he had cared a jot
about what people were going through he
would have put a stop to all of this
happening in the building that he lives
in that he's in charge of
okay we're gonna thank you all very much
there because prime minister's questions
is inevitably going to start very soon
david simmons uh for the conservative
party emily thornberry of course for
labor uh and kirsty blackman from the
snp thank you all very very much for
joining us and giving us your thoughts
uh as we all digest the details of uh
the sugray report our political editor
beth rigby still here in the studio uh
beth looking now at the bigger picture
really lots of it of sort of juicy bits
of of stories of parties and post
mortems of them but but overall how
damning would you say it is well i think
this is the big thing and this is what
we need to think about which is that
there's a string of embarrassing
revelations in this report there's
pmq's is starting let's let's listen to
the prime minister i want to begin by
echoing what you've just said that's the
reports of the fatal shooting in a texan
primary school our thoughts uh with all
those affected by this horrific attack
mr speaker yesterday i welcome the amir
of qatar to dining street it's excellent
news that qatar announced it will invest
up to 10 billion pounds into the uk
through our new strategic investment
partnership and not only will it boost
local economies and support jobs it will
support our green economy and
decarbonization
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today anthony brown
thank you mr speaker cambridge is one of
the most expensive places to live in the
country but unlike many cheaper places
nhs workers in the city get no high cost
of living supplement so nhs workers in
cambridge pay higher rents than nhs
workers in outer london boroughs like
redbridge and croydon
and bexley embarking and yet they get
paid 15 less this makes it very
difficult for the nhs in cambridge
including adam brooks hospital to retain
and recruit staff will my right
honourable friend the prime minister
work with me to make sure that nhs
workers in south cambridgeshire and
cambridge get paid fairly
prime minister my honorable friend is a
a fantastic champion for his
constituents and for uh adam brooks and
we're very proud of our nhs and that's
why we're putting record investment in
uh mr speaker and i uh uh hope that the
independent nhs pay review body i will
listen carefully at what my honorable
friend has just said we now come to the
leader of the opposition kia saba
thank you mr speaker and my thoughts
also and i know the thoughts of the
whole house are with the families of the
victims of yesterday's school shooting
in texas
nineteen children have died some as
young as seven and two adults believed
to be teachers it is an unspeakable
tragedy and our hearts are with the
american people
last weekend mark the anniversary of
both the manchester bombing and the
murder of lee rigby and we remember them
this year as we do every year
and today is also the anniversary of the
killing of george floyd a reminder that
we must all tackle the racism that is
still experienced by so many in our
country and beyond
mr speaker the sugree report was
published this morning and i look
forward to discussing that during this
afternoon statement with the prime
minister
for now i want to focus on the cost of
living affecting the whole country
mr speaker since we stood here last week
and i asked the prime minister yet again
to back labor's plans for a windfall tax
to reduce energy bills
hundreds of millions of pounds have been
added to bills of families across the
country
and hundreds of millions of pounds have
landed in the bank accounts of energy
companies it sounds like
he's finally seen sense
and the inevitable u-turn may finally
have arrived
so when can people across the country
expect him to use those oil and gas
profits to bring down their bills
[Applause]
well mr speaker there's nothing original
about a labour plan to tax uh businesses
nothing remar they want to tax business
the whole time every day labor wants to
put up taxes on business and what we're
doing is we're helping people he asks
when we're going to help people yeah
we're helping people now and mr speaker
and
we're we're putting 22 billion pounds
into uh people's pockets already cutting
uh council tax by 150 pounds cutting uh
fuel duty cutting national insurance
contributions by an average of 300 by an
average of 330 pounds for people who pay
for people who pay next and mr speaker
how can we afford that
because we have a strong economy because
we came out of covid fast mr speaker
which would not have been possible if we
listened to the party opposite
15 tax rises and it pretends for a low
tax government
it's been it's been
mr speaker it's been four and a half
months since labor first called for a
windfall tax on oil and gas profits
i've raised it week in week out and
every week he has a new reason for not
doing it
the business secretary said it's bad
the justice secretary called it
disastrous
even this weekend the health secretary
and the northern ireland secretary
opposed it
he ordered all of his mps to vote
against it last week
and now surprise surprise
he's backing it
prime minister i'm told that hindsight
is a wonderful thing
[Applause]
but mr speaker
mr speaker
whilst he's dithered and delayed
households across the country suffered
when they didn't need to
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a man who always wants to catch my eye
is not going the best way to do so okay
speaker whilst he dithered and delayed
households across the country suffered
when they didn't need to exactly
what is it about the sugray report that
first attracted him
to a u-turn this week
mr speaker mr speaker there's there is
there is no surprise
about labour's
lust there's no surprise about labour's
lust to put up taxes uh there's nothing
original about his thoughts they they
get off on it they they absolutely love
to confiscate other people's assets what
we prefer to do mr speaker is make sure
make sure that we have the measures that
are in place to drive investment in our
country and drive jobs and it's thanks
to the steps that we took uh thanks to
the fact that we came out of cobit
faster than any other european country
which would not have been possible if we
listened uh to him uh that we that we
now have unemployment at the listen to
this they used to care about this mr
speaker unemployment at the lowest level
since 1974.
and
put that in your pipe here's starman
mr speaker i actually thought with his
u-turn you might actually get his his
head out of the sand but uh obviously
not
the reality
is that
every day of his dithering and his delay
53 million pounds has been added to
britain's household bills
whilst he's distracted trying to save
his own job the country has been
counting the cost
but complacency is nothing new for this
government
back in october the chancellor delivered
a mini budget that has to be re-read to
be believed
with inflation already climbing
he said that he understood people were
concerned about it and the government
was ready to act
since then inflation has risen to a
40-year high
the highest rate of any g7 country if
the government was so ready to act six
months ago
why hasn't it
but mr speaker the government has acted
and my royal friend the chancellor
continues to act this is the government
that not only
we not only put in the living wage mr
speaker it was a conservative
institution but we've now raised it by
raised it by a record amount we've
raised it by a thousand pounds uh mr
speaker a record of mine uh we've helped
people families on universal credit have
another one thousand pounds mr speaker
thanks to the measures the 9.1 billion
pounds we've already put in uh to
support people's uh costs of heating
we're abating the costs of fuel for
people up and down the country and of
course we're going to do more mr speaker
we're going to put our arms around the
people of this country just as we did
throughout the kobe pandemic
but
but the reason we can do that is because
we took the tough decisions to drive the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe which
wouldn't have been possible if you
listen to him mr speaker and that's why
we have i literally took another
statistic youth unemployment they used
to care about it youth unemployment at
or near a record low
mr speaker it wasn't just the chancellor
back in september the prime minister
called fears about inflation unfounded
he was the last person to spot the cost
of living crisis
justice is the last person to back the
labour's plan to help people through it
and mr speaker it wasn't just on
inflation that they got it badly wrong
in the same speech the chancellor
boasted about growth prime minister does
today and we were going to do better
than all our major competitors it was
obvious that he was being complacent
yeah and lo and behold
britain is set to have the lowest growth
of any major country except russia
despite our brilliant businesses and all
we have to offer why has his government
inflicted on britain the twin-headed
hydra of the highest inflation and the
lowest growth
[Applause]
he loves running this country down
how many times how many times
how many times
how many times did he come to this place
how many times did he come to this place
and say that the united kingdom had the
highest coveted death rate in europe how
many times he was proved completely
wrong did he ever apologize mr speaker
absolutely not did he ever take it back
absolutely not mr speaker actually
because the steps we took last year we
had the fastest growth in the g7 and we
will return and we will return to the
fastest growth by
2024-2025 thanks to the decisions that
this government took mr speaker and and
they don't care about getting people
into jobs they don't care we care about
the working people of this country
making sure we have a high wage high
skill high employment economy and that's
what we're delivering
he talks about running this country down
he is running this country now
and it wasn't just complacency on
labour's windfall tax which he's now
backing it wasn't just complacency on
inflation which is now through the roof
and it wasn't just complacency on growth
which is now spluttering along at the
back of the pack because his chancellor
also claimed
that people should keep more of the
rewards of their efforts
and then he put their taxes up
[Applause]
so does the prime minister want to
explain to hard-working people whose
wages are running out sooner and sooner
each month and who are facing
astronomical bills and prices
just how his 15 tax rises since taking
office have helped them to keep more of
their rewards in their pocket
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker first of all what we're doing
is making sure after a huge pandemic uh
that we are funding our vital public
services uh which we can uh because of
the steps that we think what we're also
doing is making sure that we put more
money back into people's pockets by the
the measures that i've outlined today uh
whether through whether through cutting
national insurance contributions or
lifting or lifting the living wage or
lifting universal credit mr speaker but
all this is made possible all this is
made possible because we took the the
responsible and sensible steps to
protect our economy throughout cobid and
then to come out strongly and he's
completely wrong about this country's
growth performance mr speaker he runs it
down he runs it down he was proved wrong
about kobe he's going to be proved wrong
again
[Applause]
mr speaker
last week i raised the case of phoenix
halliwell whose kidney condition means
he needs daily dialysis and whose energy
bill has gone through the roof as a
result
i'm glad that as a result government
officials got in touch with phoenix
yesterday
and i hope that will result in more
support for people who are vulnerable
but it shouldn't be left to labour to
turn up week after week to make him
aware of the consequences of his diva
and delay
so i want to raise another issue where
the government is sleepwalking into
disaster
with the summer holidays looming there
are reports that the home office already
has a backlog of 500 000 passports to
issue
that's potentially more than half a
million people worrying whether they
will get away this summer
so can the prime minister reassure
people that they won't miss out on their
holidays due to the failures of his home
office
well i i i thank you very much but i can
tell him actually that what we're doing
is we're massively uh increasing the
speed with which the passport office uh
deliver and uh to the for the best
to the best of my knowledge everybody is
getting their passport within four
to six weeks mr speaker but that's but
but that is because that is because we
we are we are driving the leadership of
this country and uh
we are getting things done that would
never have been possible if we listen to
them we got brexit done mr speaker when
he voted
he voted 48 times 48 times he voted to
undo the will of the people we got the
vaccine road i've done whether he would
have kept in the ass in the european
medicine agency mr speaker we were the
first european country the first
european country to help the ukrainians
resist vladimir putin
yes
do you think does anybody seriously
believe for a second that they would
have done it
[Applause]
let me say very plainly does anybody
seriously think for a second that the
labor party would have done that mr
speaker
when eight eight of the shadow front
bench including the shadow foreign
secretary who is mysteriously not in his
place uh voted recently to get rid of
this country's independent nuclear
deterrence and and he campaigned he
campaigned to put vladimir corbyn i mean
sorry uh jeremy corbyn
jeremy corbyn in downing street mr
speaker
we get on we do the difficult things we
do the difficult things we take the
tough decisions mr speaker social care
social care while fixing it
prime minister we both can't be on her
feet i'm trying to help you you've got
to help me as well and i'm sure you've
got to the end because mrs stewart's
inching to get his question grabbed
stewart
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker when the prime
minister gets passionate
things get done
brexit brexit is done the vaccine
the vaccine that
if they could contain themselves the
vaccine rollout done
so will so will my right honourable
friend personally intervene
so that the immuno compromised like my
constituent scott
can get access to british wonder drug
every sheld
and then they not
not uh next winter not next year but now
so that they can enjoy this summer and
enjoy their freedom just like the rest
of us
yes mr speaker i know that the uh my my
honorable friend and has taken a keen
interest for in this for a while uh
every sheld could potentially reduce the
risk of infection as he as he says uh
we've got to look at the uh available
evidence before we can make a decision
about whether it should be available but
i will make sure that the department for
health and social care keep him updated
on the progress we're making
we now come to leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker i want to join
others today to express my deepest
sorrow at the horrific events in texas
yesterday 19 children
and two teachers
have needlessly lost their lives many of
us in scotland
will be remembering the tragic events
that took place in dunblane 26 years ago
the thoughts and prayers of the snp are
with the families suffering today but
also our hope
that lawmakers will finally act to bring
the scourge of gun violence that plagues
the united states
mr speaker the reports that the
prime minister of downing streets law
breaking have been damning
empty bottles
littering offices rooms so crowded
people were sitting on each other's laps
and security forced to intervene
because the parties were so outrageous
at the center
was the prime minister orchestrating it
grabbing a glass for himself in order to
toast the partygoers
for eight months
we've heard every excuse under the sun
but now
now
we've all seen the damning photo
evidence
well people stayed at home to protect
the nhs
the prime minister
was engaging in drinking and debauchery
that makes a mockery of the
gut-wrenching sacrifices
that each and every person made
well the prime minister
will the prime minister now take the
opportunity and resign
uh mr speaker i can i can tell the the
right honorable gentleman that uh much
as i appreciate his advice he'll have a
further opportunity which i'm i'm sure
he'll take taking his uh customary
length uh to to debate that matter uh in
the course of the statement which will
follow directly after pmq's
speaker but it's all a joke to the prime
minister
the prime minister
has lost the trust of the public
he has lost what little moral authority
he had left
the prime minister has apologized many
times not because he feels any genuine
remorse he still refuses to even admit
that there were parties and that he
presided over them
he apologized for one simple reason
he got caught
the reality is
no apology will ever be enough for the
families of people who lost loved ones
for the families who followed the rules
who stayed at home whilst their nearest
and dearest to them were dying and are
now forced to look at photographs of the
prime minister surrounded by drink
toasting to a party in the middle of a
lockdown
if the prime minister will not accept
that he must resign then the tory
benches must act
this prime minister who has broken the
law
and shown a cavalier attitude to the
truth
cannot be allowed to remain in office
prime minister
time is up
resign
resign
resign before this house is forced to
remove him
prime minister
i i i thank him very much i would uh
just uh uh direct him again i think it
would be uh to his advantage to uh look
through the report and uh and then uh i
think we should return to it after piano
keys
we now come to jonathan gillis
thank you mr speaker high streets and
heritage means a lot to the people of
stoke-on-trent north kidsgrove and talk
birds of a tonstall two of the great six
towns of stoke on trent are plagued with
rogue and absent landlords who are too
happy to let shops sit empty and
historically important buildings such as
prices in kensington teapot works fall
into ruin which is why i introduced my
proper maintenance of landfill to
increase fines on these ruinous owners
can my rightful friend confirm that as
part of the government's planning reform
he will adopt my bill which imposes a
new unlimited fine so these reckless rep
rebates can be held accountable up the
veil for saturday mr speaker
all right yeah yeah mr speaker uh
i'm out the bail but uh on the on on i
want to thank him by the way for his
campaign uh he i think he's entirely
right and that's why we've adopted the
measures that he proposes uh in the bill
uh those who leave properties derelict
unreasonably uh could face an unlimited
fine mr speaker
sir jeffrey donaldson thank you mr
speaker i was pleased to meet the prime
minister last week in royal hillsborough
in my constituency
uh we welcome his commitment to
introduce legislation to deal with the
protocol of the rsc border uh and to
protect the belfast good friday
agreement
that will take some time
in the meantime as in the rest of the
united kingdom hard-pressed households
in northern ireland are suffering from
the cost of living crisis will the prime
minister give me an assurance that any
measures that are brought forward by the
chancellor in the near future to help
hard-pressed households will apply to
northern ireland and that the protocol
will not be allowed to prevent northern
ireland citizens receiving the support
they need from the government at this
time
i i thank the right of right now
gentlemen very much uh as he knows uh we
have a package of measures
to support families across the whole of
the the uk that i've detailed already to
the house i may say that i also think it
would be an advantage to the people of
northern ireland in tackling uh the
issues that
we all face across the uk uh if if
stormont uh were to be uh restored mr
speaker
thank you mr speaker
the recent report on leveling up the
rural economy highlighted many areas
where more work is needed in small rural
and coastal communities to ensure they
also benefit from our leveling up agenda
does the prime minister agree with me
that we need to ensure levelling up
reaches into rural and coastal devon and
will my right honourable friend meet
with me and helen herford our excellent
candidate in tibetan and honniton
[Music]
how we can progress our plans for devon
yes of course mr speaker because my
honorable friend is a fantastic advocate
for devon for rural communities and i
will make sure that both she and helen
herford uh get a meeting with the
relevant uh minister to discuss her
ideas further bentley
mr speaker rising fuel costs are causing
serious problems for workers in car
dependent rural areas like heritage on
and for carers and district nurses the
situation has reached a crisis point one
carer from kerala gyorn often has to
travel 29 miles just to reach the first
service user of the day and travels
around 1700 miles each month
would the prime minister therefore
consider extending the rural fuel duty
relief scheme to areas like cara digion
to help my constituent and many like her
to continue their invaluable work
mister well i i thank you for his
excellent question and i can tell him
that uh a rural uh a few fuel duty
relief uh is there to compensate uh
motorists uh uh by helping retailers in
some uh more remote rural areas where
pump prices can be significantly uh
higher it currently operates on a
geographical basis but mr speaker i'm
very happy uh to ensure that uh the
honourable gentleman gets a meeting with
the uh the relevant minister as fast as
possible stevenson mr speaker
labor and socialism has failed this
country because they've followed
policies which interfere too much in
people's lives
over regulate spend too much taxpayers
money borrow too much and raise taxes
could the prime minister tell the house
what policies his governments are going
to follow to ensure we don't have a
similar fate
yes mr speaker i i can and i'm i'm
grateful to to uh to my honorable friend
and he's absolutely right uh that
labor's instinct everywhere and always
is to put up tax with all its
abs that's what they well they're there
they're bragging about it today mr
speaker it's ludicrous uh and uh what we
are doing is not only cutting uh
people's contributions under national
insurance but also cutting uh the uh
cutting the uh helping people helping
businesses to invest with the 130
percent super deduction uh that my
vulnerable friend uh put in and what
that is doing is helping us to have a
high wage high skill economy with
unemployment that's why i said this
performance speaker at the lowest since
1974. job fairness yeah yeah yeah thank
you mr speaker days before the election
of disgrace former conservative mp imran
ahmad khan his victim warned the
conservative party of the abuse he had
suffered
[Music]
there's still i think an appeal and sub
judaism so if you can be careful just
word the question
shockingly they fail to act on this
report and still won't explain why
that's why rotherham child sexual
exploitation survivor sammy woodhouse
has called for an independent
investigation into the failure warning
that the conservative party have broken
the trust of victims so will the prime
minister personally back of those calls
and launch an independence investigation
until the failure to act so that victims
can have confidence that his party will
never again turn a blind item
well mr speaker i i hear what she says
and uh and the sensitivity of the issues
that she uh that she raises i think that
though uh given the legal proceedings
that are currently uh are going on i i
don't i don't think it would be i don't
think it would be right to comment any
further
[Music]
thank you mr speaker while the politics
of politics often gets all the attention
back in the real world millions of
parents are being held back by issues
with child care schemes that have been a
muddle over governments of all political
colours and i declare a quite obvious
interest
the taxpayer is spending five to six
billion quid a year but we have some of
the highest costs in the world during a
cost of living square in swedes and
stroud parents and early years educators
are really stuck with the bureaucracy i
know my right honourable friend has
personally asked ministers to
investigate options to reduce the cost
of child care will he tell us a little
bit more about what we can do urgently
and work with me with the think tank
onward where we do our reforms
yeah yeah well yes mrs b i thank her
very much and she and i put by this this
is a subject which i take a direct
personal interest and i think mr speaker
that the uh there are things that we can
do to make child care more affordable
one of the one of the issues is that not
enough people take up uh tax-free child
care we need we need to have more
take-up of what is what is on offer uh
but what we can also look at mr speaker
is ways in which we can reform and
improve the system or obsession
thank you mr speaker next month marks
five years since the horrific grenfell
fire tower
which killed 72 people my constituency
vauxhall has many tall buildings similar
to grenfell in 2019 the prime minister
rightly told this house
where the inquiry recommends government
responsibility for fire safety we will
legislate accordingly
but mr speaker last week the government
dropped the inquiry's recommendation
that personal evacuation plan should be
in place for disabled residents
claiming basic safety would be too
expensive
grenfell united said that this showed
that cutting costs is more important
than the value of human life so will the
prime minister urgently reverse this
deeply inhumane decision and not break
another promise to this house
[Applause]
mr speaker let's be clear if there is an
issue with fire safety in this in a
building uh then extra steps should be
taken and uh and remediation uh should
be made and when it comes to
self-evacuation mr speaker the home
office has launched a new uh
consultation to support the fast safety
of residents who are unable uh to self
to self-evacuate but if she has further
representations to make on that point
i'll be very happy to ensure she gets a
meeting uh with the minister in duluth
mr speaker i am not a cynical salt
but i was
i was slightly perplexed this week uh
when the cabinet secretary and the
director of government propriety and
ethics no less were banned from
attending my committee to give evidence
which has been scheduled for two months
i i cannot possibly think why mr speaker
but i wonder which particular subjects
my right honourable friend the prime
minister was most concerned being raised
by my committee
was it the case of undeclared loans and
donations in kind
security insights into appointments to
the house of lords or indeed the
consultation of the propriety and ethics
units and ministerial appointments
[Music]
mr speaker i i i can assure him i know
he's not a cynic he's a knife he's one
of nature's idealist mr speaker and
i i will make sure that uh all relevant
ministers and civil servants uh appear
before his committee
claire
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
is leading a long queue of conservatives
mps lining up to show how out of touch
they are bills are rising people are
struggling a quarter of people in
working putney earn less than the london
living wage they don't need to be told
how to budget better to learn how to
cook to buy value food they already are
when will the prime minister get a grip
on this crisis and when will he bring in
the windfall tax yes
mr speaker what we're doing for the
people of putney and the people
throughout this country uh is making
sure that we invest now in protecting
them as i've said to the highest and
i've said uh repeatedly uh not just with
the increases in the in universal credit
or in the in the living wage uh in the
in the warm homes discount in uh in
cutting fuel bills but also of course uh
with a 330 pounds cut in in nick's uh mr
speaker but the reason we can do this is
because we have a robust uh economic
position in which we have strong
employment that is giving us the revenue
to pay and to cushion people in this
difficult time it would not have been
possible if we'd listened to the labour
party during kobe mccartney thank you mr
speaker this weekend tens of thousands
of huddersfield sporting fans are coming
down to london on saturday huddersfield
giants are in their first rugby league
challenge cup final for over a decade
and on sunday it's huddersfield town in
the championship playoff final for a
place in the premier league will the
prime minister as well as wishing the
best of luck to both huddersfield teams
agree with me that the best way that
labour run kirkley's council can honor
the sporting tradition of huddersfield
is following through with their pledge
to house the new national rugby league
museum in huddersfield in the birthplace
the george hotel and not pull out of
that deal as they've indicated they want
to do something
that is that is that the labor council
pulling out of their deal
well this is big i i i'm not i'm not i'm
not surprised uh all i can say is i i
congratulate him on his on his campaign
for a national rugby league uh museum
and i urge him uh to take it up with the
arts council or
or other relevant bodies andy mcdonald
thank you mr speaker
under the cover of the pandemic we've
seen a massive shift in wealth from the
poorest to the richest a partying pm and
a law-breaking ritualist chancellor have
lined the pockets of their wealthy pals
whilst upwards of one hundred and
seventy five thousand of our fellow
citizens have died from kovid and
they're now sitting on their hands and
laughing in our faces as the cost of
living crisis and fuel poverty could
well leave thousands more to die of cold
in their own homes so mr speaker when we
saw pictures of the pm partying in the
middle of the pandemic was he toasting
his assault on the working class and i
asked him
how on earth does he sleep at night with
so much blood on his filthy privileged
hands
[Applause]
mr speaker uh from from furlough onwards
everything we have done since the
pandemic began has been to get
money into the pockets of the working
people of this country and those are the
people those are the people time and
again uh that we have prioritized and i
do not for a moment i do not for a
moment doubt mr speaker that things that
things are tough i do not doubt it for a
moment but it is our intention to get
this country through it and we will get
through it very well by putting our arms
around people as we can and as we will
because of the fiscal firepower that we
have mr speaker but also by making sure
that we continue with the high wage high
skill high employment economy that we
have and the best thing for to get money
into people's pockets mr speaker is to
have a job
jill mortimer
does the prime minister agree with me
that when the right honourable member
opposite spins his myth of a low-tax
labour party he clearly needs a memory
job
because
can i just remind you all that in 2019
you all stood on a manifesto that would
have inflicted the highest tax burden
from the people of this country
that's probably why there's so few of
you over there
yes mr speaker they they campaigned to
put up taxes on business to the highest
level this country has ever seen that
was his ambition uh mr speaker and
that's what that is what they would do
again be in no doubt that's what they
love to do you can feel the lust for tax
rising off that off those benches
opposite mr speaker and that is why
there's never been a labor government
that left office with unemployment lower
than when they came in mr wakefield
thank you mr speaker
yesterday the head of off gem advised
the mps that the energy cap is due to
increase to 2 800 pounds in the autumn
more than double from last year and i
know the prime minister has been busy
drafting and redrafting his offer is
half-assed apologies rather than helping
the people at very south but at which
work event
[Applause]
but at which work event did he realize
labor's call was right thing to do
considering he and his party voted
against it last week is it just the same
his own neck
i couldn't either hear the question or
the advice i was being given it might be
helpful i could hear both prime minister
did you manage to hear it very much well
i i heard enough mr speaker to have a
rough idea of the nonsense that he was
talking
what we're doing uh mr speaker is not
only supporting people now but we will
continue to put our arms around the
people of this country as we did as we
did during the pandemic and beyond
can i just say moderate language is what
we normally use i don't find it it
doesn't suit the churn i don't think it
suits the country so please john barron
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will recall i've previously
raised with him the plight of 170
british council contractors who remain
in afghanistan in fear of their lives 85
of whom are deemed to be at very high
risk i met the refugee minister last
week it was a positive meeting but we
faced bureaucracy which is preventing
the fcdo from cutting through that um
bureaucracy and helping these people now
courtesy of the acrs scheme will he help
us cut through that red tape and help
these people we owe them a debt of
obligation and time is running out
uh well i i thank him very very much
i'll see what we can do to help those
particular people but i just remind the
house
that we've not only evacuated fifteen
thousand people underwrote pitting it
was a great uh credit to this country uh
we've supported since then since then
four thousand six hundred more uh have
come uh to this country and i will do
what we can to help the people that he
mentions
mr speaker jubilee lead academy in my
constituency working with nottingham
citizens recently asked me to visit the
school to hear about their low pay
campaign they're tired of seeing people
in our community working hard but living
in poverty and now bills are rising
inflation's at nine percent and yet the
government seems incapable and frankly a
little disinterested in doing anything
to help out mr speaker our children can
see the need for emergency action why
can't our government yeah
mr speaker everybody everybody in work
uh 30 million workers will get a tax cut
in july on top of everything that we're
already doing but that is not the uh the
end of what this government is going to
do to look after people and i've told
the house
before this morning this afternoon uh
that we will continue to use our fiscal
firepower to look after the british
people through the kobe doctor shocks
and beyond williams
thank you mr speaker on monday at 3 25 a
school bus crashed into a group of
school children in flamvacranian three
children were airlifted to hospital with
another child and the bus driver taken
by ambulance and a fifth child was
discharged at the scene everyone is in a
stable condition
clearly this is a tragic accident that
will stay with the community for some
time will the prime minister join me and
i'm sure the whole house in sending our
love and prayers to those in hospital
and we also praise the teaching staff of
both the primary high school the world
share ambulance david powers police for
their heroic response and their
continuing response to the community
[Applause]
i i thank my honorable friend for
raising this this very very sad incident
and i'm sure that the whole house uh his
thoughts mr speaker will be with those
who have been affected and i want to
join him in particular in uh paying
tribute uh to the emergency services uh
but also of course the teachers of the
staff of the school uh who did so much
to help
johnny antonio
thank you mr speaker
prime minister
my constituent robert walker sadly died
last year
he worked for mi6 and has such
disclosing confidence that he was a gay
man
this confidence was breached by the hr
department at the foreign commonwealth
office
recently unearthed paperwork showed that
this breach largely accounted for his
well-being and enforced early retirement
would the prime minister offer bob's
partner stephen honeyman a posthumous
apology and commit to ask the foreign
commonwealth office for a formal
response to his treatment while he
worked at mi6
prime minister well mr speaker i want to
begin by by saying how grateful i am to
the uh honourable member for uh for
raising this case uh but i i have to
tell her i'm afraid i uh don't know
directly about uh the uh the events that
she described uh what she says is very
concerning i'll make sure that she gets
a meeting with the relevant minister uh
as soon as
possible aims prime minister's questions
for those who wish to leave
[Laughter]
we know
can i can i just say to the house i
expect moderate and temperament language
as we come to the statement prime
minister
thank you mr speaker
with with permission i will make a
statement